[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
horizon forbidden west is one of the
most hotly anticipated games of the year
releasing on february 18th i thought now
is a great time to put together a video
about all the new things coming to
horizon forbidden west and how the game
has changed from horizon zero dawn so
whether you're an og horizon fan from
2017 maybe you first played when the
game was given away for free last year
or even if you thought eli was only a
character in fortnite here's everything
new in horizon forbidden west
the first thing you need to know is
about how to save yourself a little
money horizon forbidden west is only
available on ps4 and ps5 but get this
there is a free upgrade if you buy the
ps4 version the thing is the playstation
4 version is drastically cheaper than
the playstation 5 version so if you have
a ps5 and want to save 10 pounds or
euros simply buy the ps4 version and
freely upgrade to your current system
don't tell playstation i told you this
so let's set the scene the new story
picks up roughly six months after eloy
defeated hades in zero dawn i'll link a
story recap video if you need a
refresher the tribes we met now live in
harmony but suddenly a new issue arrives
a red blight covers the ground infecting
flora and fauna causing sickness and
superstorm spiral out of control in the
skies above the world needs saving again
so eloi picks up her spear again and
ventures into the new world the
forbidden west but where the heck is the
forbidden west well it's in the usa and
sees us traveling to the pacific ocean
via the mountains of utah passing
through the deserts of nevada
encountering new enemies and machines
along the way and we'll get to those
machines very soon in 2017 we started
with a combat spear for basic melee
action but quickly disregarded it in
favor of archery the developers have
seen this issue and made sure forbidden
west improves upon it as eloy spear is
now called to combat and just as
important as her bow improved striking
and a combo system will make eloy a
worthy opponent up close and personal
the idea is that we will freely change
up our attacks between spear and bow
during fights and to emphasize this we
have something called a resonator blast
by charging a power spear in melee
combat we can transfer that energy into
an enemy and then shoot them with an
arrow to cause massive damage another
addition sees this animation which i
cannot get enough of a loy has a limit
break this is the valor surge feature in
which eloy adds an effect to her weapon
before planting it in the ground and
affecting everyone around her to
activate valor surge players will have
to fill up an energy bar this is done by
accumulating combat xp from successfully
hitting headshots or removing components
from machines when the valasurge energy
bar is full enough players will be able
to unleash it there will be a total of
12 valor surges to unlock and they can
be upgraded along three tiers and
there's risk reward here the higher
level valor surges will take longer to
charge up but they will produce a far
more powerful attack to choose our valor
surges we must decide which skill tree
to upgrade in horizon zero dawn we have
three skill trees with a fourth added in
the dlc in forbidden west we have six
skill trees immediately all tied to play
style the skill trees are warrior hunter
trapper survivor infiltrator and machine
master our new skills are key to
fighting our new foes both machine and
man forbidden west's ai has been
considerably improved so much so that
enemy tribes have the ability to
override machines and fight with them in
unison for example a tremor tusk with a
raider on board will fight differently
to the machine if you found it in the
wilds which will then fight differently
from a group of human enemies without
any machine help a light will need to
react on the fly and change up her
playstyle to suit the adapting foes all
this has been done to force us to use
more of our weapons in our inventory
instead of finding that one overpowered
skill and spamming it continuously
combat variation looks to be more
improvised and intense
in 2017 horizon zero dawn released in
the same week as breath of the wild
which immediately changed our
expectations for open world gaming and
thankfully gorilla have taken note and
more elements from link's adventures
have found their way into forbidden west
free climbing is one of those updates we
desperately needed previously we were
ordered to use only a handful of ledges
to traverse whereas in forbidden west
much more of the world is ascendable
this isn't the total freedom of
something like gentian impact but it is
way more freedom this time around by
pushing r3 allies focus will scan the
area for ledges and outline them in this
yellow we also have access to the
pullcaster a kind of grappling hook
which lets aylei quickly reach high
areas or reposition almost immediately
useful to get the drop on enemies or
escape to fight another day it doesn't
stop there either now we can climb
higher and find new areas to discover we
need a way to safely get back down which
is why we have the shield wing nobody
wants to slowly climb back down a rock
face or mountain top we want to jump off
safely and that's why the shield wing is
perfect in addition to that climbable
world above us a new element of horizon
sees a world underneath beneath the
waves eloy once she obtains breathing
apparatus can now fully submerge and
freely swim around underwater visually
well look at it wow it's just stunning
but there are new mechanics under here
to be aware of underwater currents fight
back as we swim through them pushing a
light off course and of course there are
new machines in the waters too swimming
free climbing grappling hook and the
glider all these new elements
revolutionize alois traversal abilities
and we can even chain these skills
together to find secret new areas
let's go over to the settlements now hub
towns that eloy can freely visit in-game
the level of detail here is mind-blowing
and get this each npc has a timetable to
keep they have working times they have
sleep schedules and unique animations
the idea is to make settlements as
realistic as possible to hit home who
you are trying to save in this mission
and each of those settlements is
different it's unique to each tribe that
it represents this is a place to pick up
quests to upgrade gear with workbenches
to visit a stitcher to buy a new outfit
or take part in a melee pit a battle
area to fight against other tribesmen or
if you really want a challenge look out
for the arena a place to take on
machines in captivity in front of a
watching crowd gladiator style and each
of these challenges has a reward a piece
of loot a gear upgrade so maybe don't
leave these until after the credits roll
settlements are a great place to find
something new in horizon a new board
game played by the inhabitants of the
forbidden west machine strike it's
called we don't know much about it right
now but if gwent or orlog have taught me
anything these minigames will take up a
lot of our time one of the best things
about horizon zero dawn was a sidequest
system which saw people you helped
earlier in the game returning the favor
in the final battle this system has been
embraced fully in forbidden west in many
games you'll find that side quest givers
tend to vanish after that one single
transaction with them whereas in horizon
their impact is felt further they will
return later in the game and drop in and
out of the story never really fading
into the background better than that are
the improved rewards for completing side
quests in the forbidden west each extra
mission we choose could reward us with
something which drastically changes our
playstyle some of the side quests we
know about include hunting grounds you
know what that is salvage contracts in
which we must carefully dismantle a
machine in a fight for rare parts and
races are a thing too overriding
machines like hot wiring a car it looks
like there's a ton to do outside of the
car story
okay let's talk about the elephant in
the room new machines horizon forbidden
west is confirmed to have dozens of new
machine types living in the world there
will also be some returning from zero
dawn let's take a look at some of the
new ones the tremor tusk is a mammoth
beast with cannons on its side to ward
off flankers its charge and slam looks
devastating but its slow turning circle
appears to be the tremortusk's weakness
the clamber jaws are simian-like
creatures monkeying around these chaps
hunt in groups and climb to claim the
high ground above you just like obi-wan
the clawstriders are the velociraptors
of horizon yet their teeth are chainsaw
blades
rollerbacks are like a mechanical
armadillo with a tough protective shell
they will use these to roll into a ball
and squash you lovely shell snappers
remind me of the pokemon torterra a
tortoise-like being who hides in swamps
and marshlands around the forbidden west
a returning machine is the snapmaw but
now they have the water to freely swim
in we'll likely meet them under the
waves back in 2017 snap mars were
vulnerable to fire damage but i don't
think we can fight them that way when
we're underwater hmm the snapmore is
suddenly a much more potent predator and
then we have the pterodactyl-like sun
wings a flying machine cool fact their
wings are actually solar panels kool-aid
and my personal favorite is the
slitherfang a huge sand cobra which
moves and attacks like no other machine
continually moving slithering and
disappearing underground before
attacking without notice but that belly
does look quite weak so that's just
seven of the new machines that have been
revealed so far there are supposedly
dozens more to find for ourselves when
horizon forbidden west releases on
february 18th and to finish it all where
we started the ps4 and ps5 versions of
verizon forbidden west are indeed the
same game but of course there are
improvements on the playstation 5 you
should know about firstly everything
will look a little bit more impressive
draw distances detail lighting the real
changes though happen with load times as
the ps5 has that crazy fast ssd which
makes the game run with almost zero load
times elsewhere the audio on ps5 sees
improvement and of course the dual sense
controller offers haptic feedback and
adaptive triggers unlike the dual shock
the feeling of tension as your bowstring
pulls back never gets old it's really
cool but it isn't vital to play the game
the little touches which help immersion
are only available on playstation 5. so
there you go 20 new things coming to
horizon forbidden west i'm adam you're
awesome i'll see you next time